nous sommes le 6 octobre 2016 dernière
édition du 7 8 les invités pour cette
semaine rencontre avec celles et ceux
qui font l'actualité dans le département
et aujourd'hui vous entendrez jean-marc
le rudulier le maire de buc sa commune
accueille une nouvelle édition du
festival de la bande dessinée le
neuvième art à l'honneur parrain cette
année baptême le dessinateur du
marsupilami de nombreux auteurs sont
aussi attendus et puis jean-pierre pia
le directeur de la batterie à guyancourt
elle nous présentera les grandes lignes
de sa programmation pour cette nouvelle
saison la saison qui s'est ouvert
vendredi dernier jean marc le régulier
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le maire de
buc et donc le premier invité ce soir
nous allons évoquer cette nouvelle
édition du festival que vous accueillez
que vous organisez même
c'est la 23e année pour ce festival déjà
toujours un incontournable
est ce qu'il ya des nouveautés cette
année on va commencer par ça il ya des
nouveautés parce que d'abord le festival
ne se fait pas dans le château puisque
le château est en travaux pour l'instant
mais nous avons installé 800 m 2 800 m²
de tente donc nous faisons ça dans le
parc du château et tout se passera très
bien au niveau haut niveau au niveau des
auteurs c'est une cinquantaine d'auteurs
comme d'habitude c'est les français bien
sûr mais aussi c'est un festival un peu
international puisqu'on accueille cette
année des serbes ont accueilli un
canadien on a cueilli un espagnol et on
accueille mais ma chinois donc c'est
vraiment très cosmopolite
c'est l'occasion de voir la diversité de
la bande dessinée les différents styles
il n'y a pas que la bd franco belge n'a
ni les moyens vous le verrez en vendant
sur le festival qui se déroulera samedi
et dimanche et puis dès le vendredi soir
alors dès le vendredi soir on ouvre
comme l'année dernière on avait commencé
inauguré sa on ouvre ce festival par la
projection d'un film
cette année c'est la projection d'un
film astérix
qui va ouvrir le festival et ça ça a
lieu au théâtre des arcades à buc des
projections une projection des
expositions des séances d'alors 15
expositions et puis alors évidemment
pendant les deux jours beaucoup de
séances dédicaces en fait c'est
l'occasion pour les collectionneurs du
de la france entière et même au delà de
venir enrichir leur collection là il
faut il faut il faut admettre que c'est
vrai qu'il ya des gens qui sont là
depuis le festival ouvre à 10h le samedi
il ya des gens qui sont là depuis 3
heures du matin devant les parcs devant
les grilles du château et qui qui
dorment là même et qui attendent et
attendre l'ouverture pour être les
premiers
on quitte le monde culturel mais juste
une parenthèse sur l'organisation
surtout en cette période où les choses
sont vendus encore plus compliquée avec
la toutes les normes de sécurité qui
sont en pause et alors effectivement
nous on est dans l'enceinte du parc du
château donc c'était c'est une enceinte
qui est fermée si vous voulez donc
effectivement on a on a on a eu des
contacts avec les préfectures pour
expliquer un peu ce qu'on faisait on n'a
pas eu de remarque particulière
seulement il y aura qu'une seule entrée
c'est vrai pour la première fois bon
nous fera un peu d'eux on fera des
inspections de sacs et des choses comme
ça je pense que c'est un festival qui
devrait se passer comme d'habitude très
normalement on le dit souvent lorsqu'on
évoque ce festival met la ville de bucca
une longue histoire avec la bande
dessinée on va tout moment en reparler
plus particulièrement avec blake et
mortimer avec blake et mortimer 16h sur
l'anecdote après ça ça ça c'est vraiment
on s'aperçoit là que le dessinateur de
blake et mortimer a vraiment été à but
pour dessiner parce que on retrouve
encore des restes de
deux bus de bâtiments qui la photographe
pas photographier qui l'a pas pour
l'album sos météores 1959 et c'est 1959
quoi ces vieux donc c'est vrai que et
danse album des services météo on trouve
le château de buc
et comme par hasard on a fait le fait
c'est le premier festival de la bande
dessinée dans le château de buc comment
vous faites le choix des auteurs parce
que vous élaborez ce festival tout au
long de l'année ça ne se fait pas la
dernière minute comme ça se fait ça se
fait tout au long de l'année
effectivement moi même et mes
collaboratrices si vous voulez du du
service culturel madame tamini à nice
madame annie sata minimes adams aussi
court madame divaret toute l'année sont
à la recherche effectivement et puis on
fait il y à il ya des bénévoles aussi
des amateurs de bandes dessinées des
bénévoles qui nous aident largement et
par exemple moi par exemple je suis allé
cette année au festival de la bande
dessinée de sollièsville solliès ville
c'est dans le bras
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer des
auteurs que j'avais déjà vu abus et on
renoue des contacts et on peut nouer des
contacts et intentions parlant note
estivale et on s'aperçoit finalement que
le festival de buts est très connu c'est
pas encore le festival d'angoulême non
les sabres à moulins
voilà vous aller concurrencer angoulême
au virage là le parrain cette année
ces baptêmes c'est lui qui a signé la
fiche du festival également et puis il a
collaboré avec les différentes écoles ne
voulant prendre mais il ya eu ce petit
agenda et qui a été réalisé avec les
élèves sur les différents dessins qui
ont été faits baptême bien évidemment a
assigné la couverture elle nous l'avons
rencontré baptême il ya quelques mois je
vous propose de redécouvrir ce reportage
qui ne vous n'avez pas encore vu
consacrer à son travail avec les écoles
regarder
le festival bd de buc un incontournable
depuis 20 ans pour les amateurs du
neuvième art scénariste et dessinateur
s'y succèdent chaque année en octobre
prochain parrain de l'événement le colin
connu sous le nom d'artiste de baptême à
28 albums du marsupilami à son actif un
animal imaginaire créé en 1952 par
franquin pour les besoins d'une histoire
de deux autres héros légendaire spirou
et fantasio
actuellement c'est avec de jeunes élèves
yvelinois des communes de
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
que baptême mène un travail de
sensibilisation à l'environnement
andry frank était lui-même très très
sensible à l'écologie et manger toujours
été j'ai toujours été proche de nature
je faisais du scoutisme et le
marsupilami qui vit en pleine nature et
qui doit défendre son environnement
effectivement deux points je dirais des
dents le troisième album même peut-être
le deuxième est essentiellement le
troisième album qui marque ce noir avec
liane nous avons traité d'écologie ce
travail de plusieurs semaines permettra
l'édition d'un agenda scolaire
distribués dans les écoles du secteur à
la rentrée
quant aux marsupilami baptême entend
bien lui assurer et longue vie
ces aventures sa rage dans les cours de
récréation alain chabat lui a même
consacré un film en 2012
je voudrais exploiter la forêt comme un
personnage à part entière que cette
végétation c'est de nature prennent
vraiment une part essentielle dans les
histoires et on en revient à l'écologie
et c'est pour ça que le marsupilami
dialogue personnages tout trouvé pour
faire ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
avec les enfants et mais maintenant il
faudra abandonner que pour le pas
tourner en rond que cette j'apprenne
peut-être une autre dimension comme
personnage peut-être aller depuis une
dizaine années mélange de travail avec
ce département qui a donné notre
orientation appel à ces lignes un peu
plus magique vers une forme de
chamanisme présent à buc les 8 et 9
octobre prochain baptême ne manquera pas
d'échanger avec les bédéphiles sur celui
qu'il surnomme l'animal magique à
plusieurs reprises j'ai pu constater que
lorsque j'allais le vert en dédicace son
séance de dédicaces pour rencontrer les
lecteurs
très rap si si j'ai la chance d'être sur
un stand avec d'écoeurer avec les choux
l'autre du marsupilami ou une
reconstitution de niwa posters ou
l'autre les enfants sont attirés à telle
enseigne que lorsqu'il arrive l'heure
toujours demandent eux alors c'est pour
toi dessins que ce que tu veux ballet
national pouvait blesser le gros chien
jaune là bas ils n'ont jamais vue ils me
connaissent ni d'eve ni d'adam
connaissent même pas le nom mais il ya
une magie qui opère cet animal jaune
seconde ses grands yeux blancs et des
taches noires
rappelons que évidemment la liste des
auteurs présents au festival n'a pas
encore été dévoilée l'an passé c'est
nicolas tabary et son héros iznogoud qui
était à l'honneur
et depuis ce reportage réalisé en mars
bien évidemment la liste a été dévoilée
un des auteurs je vous renvoie vers le
site de la ville de buc pour avoir le
détail de la programmation le festival
qui dépasse le cadre de la commune vous
associez aussi on a parlé tout à l'heure
du rayonnement minimum national du
festival mais sur cette échelle locale
il ya aussi une association avec
versailles grand parc avec la migration
bonvarlet de ce travail qui a été mené
et qui a abouti sur je leur montre ce
petit agenda fait par les élèves
tout à fait et cesser ces huit mille
cinq cents exemplaires de ce petit
agenda qui ont été distribués aux
enfants et aux leurs familles sur le
thème de l'environnement
le tri des déchets
et l'eau enfin tout un les causes du
réchauffement climatique les les
énergies renouvelables donc ce travail
était ponctuelle avec une agglomération
verse alors ce projet est ponctuelle
avec l'agglomération de versailles grand
parc et en collaboration avec
l'éducation nationale sur toi qui est
partie prenante qui a été partie
prenante dans l'élaboration de cet
agenda
quel développement vous pouvez espérer
pour ce festival vous parler de
concurrence et angoulême
oui voilà que messieurs dans la vie mais
on est ambitieux savez on a commencé la
première année il y avait je crois 15
cents entrées l'année dernière on a fait
plus de 6700 en très bon cette année ont
pensé passer on va dépasser à mon avis
on va atteindre des 8000 9000 peut-être
dix mille on verra il vous resterait
toujours sur but coup justement on peut
imaginer alors effectivement pour
l'instant on reste sur but mais on
réfléchit effectivement avec versailles
grand parc à faire tourner ce festival
il faudrait qu'il tourne mais pour
l'instant il est bloqué à buc et ce sera
à buc pour ce week end mais est revenu
en plateau pour nous le présenter les
parm il ya un travail qui est mené pour
que les visiteurs sont accueillis dans
les meilleures conditions les amateurs
du neuvième art on va rester dans la
culture pour continuer ce set 8 invités
nous allons partir pour la batterie à
guyancourt nous attend jean pierre piacé
le directeur camille lambert
l'interrogeait sur la programmation de
cette saison voilà bien commun
voilà c'est tout
devant deux mille ans
je vais vous parler d'abord du début de
la saison puisque la suite ce sera une
surprise
nous faisons comme d'habitude une
programmation au trimestre comme à
l'habitude avec avec la batterie une
programmation extrêmement éclectique on
va on va aller vers un vers le jazz en
valais en la chanson française mais
aussi du métal du rock blues etc
donc c'est extrêmement variés comme on
en a l'habitude tous ceux qui suivent
une esthétique sont à peu près sûr de
trouver leur bonheur une fois dans le
trimestre au bois avec la programmation
qui se fait ici on a par exemple julien
lourau qui va venir avec médéric
collignon et puis aussi robbie de
bennett est pris à eric landais qui est
un saxophoniste qui viendra non
seulement en résidence mais qui viendra
aussi enregistrer un album live avec le
public de vue en cours
le groupe est ce qui malheureusement
suite aux attentats l'an dernier avait
été déprogrammé et donc on va les
retrouver cette année en rock rock et
rock blues on a des grandes pointures
qui accueille qui sont les musiciens de
tenir after d'abord le groupe mythique
et puis aussi bandeau friends qui est en
fait ce sont les musiciens de rory
gallagher là aussi autres grands goodman
disparu mais ils sont reformer le groupe
ils ont changé de guitaristes chanteurs
évidemment c'est vraiment impressionnant
à écouter c'est à la perfection on
retrouve vraiment toute la grande époque
de ces groupes
non
à
à la batterie à de billancourt on trouve
un public qui est vraiment extrêmement
large qui est bien avec des avec des
profils très différents qui peuvent
venir aussi bien david et guyancourt que
de son agglomération voire du
département et parfois au delà tout
dépend évidemment de la fiche que l'on
va proposer certaines affiches vont
avoir un public un peu plus local on
travaille aussi avec les amateurs si si
puisqu'on fait osciller soirée boeuf ce
qu'on appel d'offres déjanté ici les
attentes pour cette année c'est c'est de
pouvoir continuer tout le travail de
fond que l'on réalise ici notamment dans
l'accompagnement des artistes en voie de
développement notamment au travers de
résidence donc c'est tout le travail que
le public ne voit pas tout toute la
journée mais on a des artistes en
permanence qui viennent travailler sur
notre scène et puis qui ensuite joue sur
le plateau à l'occasion deux premières
parties d'artistes plus reconnu qui
passe par ici c'est la fin de cette
édition demain vendredi vous avez rendez
vous avec nikola kirillovitch et son
invité pour refaire le fil de
l'actualité de la semaine pour vos idées
sorties du week-end ce sera avec camille
lambert pour le 7-8 loisirs on se
retrouve lundi pour un nouveau journal
est un nouveau module du 7-8 les invités